Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I am...
I'm very tired.
Because I have... Happy American Thanksgiving, by the way!
I took a nap.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I don't know why I keep doing this to myself.
I'm like... I'll be like... I took a nap at like 4 p.m.
I was like, it'll be fine.
It'll be okay.
I can handle it.
It's like... I can handle it.
I don't know why past Stokke is always like this.
Past Stokke is always like... You already know... I don't know.
I always feel like it'll be different.
Every time I nap...
Every time I think about napping before stream, I keep telling myself, today will be different.
Today, my body will figure it out.
Like, eventually, you know?
Okay, so I found out.
Okay, this is sort of related.
So like...
Apparently, there's this YouTube video of this lady finding out that being lactose intolerant is literally just a skill issue.
You can force yourself to... By the way, don't do this.
For legal reasons, do not do this.
Anyway, so she found out.
She read a paper.
And found out that you can train your body to not be lactose intolerant.
So what she did was that she drank skim milk every single day until she stopped being lactose intolerant.
And it worked.
Like, it actually helped the body to realize you can actually train yourself to be less allergic to things.
If you just like...
By the way, for legal and medical reasons, do not like...
I'm an anime girl on the internet.
Please do not listen to me.
Please...
But I thought that video was very...
I thought...
I thought that video was...
Do not try this.
Especially if you are allergic to peanuts.
Do not try this if you need an EpiPen to fucking live.
But...
It was a very interesting video.
Not actual medical advice.
Anyway, I saw that video.
I thought I was like...
Apparently, lactose intolerant might be a skill issue.
I'm not lactose intolerant.
I know a lot of Asians are actually born with being lactose intolerant.
Because we don't have...
A lot of Asians didn't have...
Grew up with milk and cheese.
Because I guess...
Back in the day...
Hundreds of years ago...
When we saw...
I don't know...
Cow titty milk.
We were like...
I guess.
That's weird.
I don't know.
And then it was brought in by...
The West.
But then we didn't...
Back then...
It's like...
So...
Cheese is like...
I know cheese in general is considered...
Considered like...
Like something for like Western side.
Bring it over.
It's not really an allergy.
Well, anyway.
But she basically drank skim milk every single day.
And it somehow became less lactose intolerant.
And...
So like we did...
So like...
Especially like within like Asians.
We don't have like the enzyme to digest it properly.
I don't know why we fucking suck with alcohol.
I remember like...
I don't remember the historical reason why we suck with alcohol as well.
For those who don't know.
Asians don't have the enzyme to digest alcohol properly.
So alcohol is considered poisonous to Asians.
And that's why we have the red flesh.
Because we don't digest it properly.
So...
Because we can't digest it properly.
We get red more easily.
So I don't know why...
The historical reasons why we can't do that.
But I know the milk...
The reasons why we're lactose intolerant.
I'm not lactose intolerant by the way.
I'm fine.
Luckily I like...
I like was fine with that.
But it's more poisonous to Asians.
And that is why we have the...
The red flesh that we get easily.
But yeah.
So I was thinking...
I saw that video.
And then I was like...
And I was like...
Oh my god.
What if I can do that with napping?
I was like...
Maybe eventually...
My body will get used to napping before stream.
So like when I wake up eventually...
Maybe I won't feel dead inside.
That's like...
That's where my mind went to.
So I was like...
Okay.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Maybe this time it will be different.
Maybe my body...
Will build a tolerance to napping before stream.
So when I wake up...
I'll be okay.
That's where everything connected.
Okay.
By the way.
Don't do this.
This is some fucking girl that read a paper...
In the mid 19...
Like early 1900s.
Okay.
The weirdest part...
Was that the paper was from the early 1900s too.
And then she was like...
You know what?
That seems right.
I'm gonna test that theory out.
And then she did that everyday.
And then even she was like...
Don't do this guys.
Like...
Yes.
I like...
Now I can like...
Drink milk again.
I can drink milk properly.
But she was like...
Don't do this guys.
It was not fun.
And I was like...
Like...
I don't know what it's like to be lactose intolerant.
But it definitely did not seem very fun.
I was like...
At least she can drink milk now.
But yeah.
Anyway.
A little fun fact about the history of milk.
This is why in Asia...
You visit Asia.
Like any country in Asia.
You'll see like...
The different flavors of milk that they have.
Not just like chocolate milk.
But like...
They'll have like banana milk.
And like...
Different types of flavors of milk.
Because it was saying...
Because like...
It actually...
Banana milk as well too.
It like...
Lessens the effects of lactose.
Those who have lactose intolerant.
It like...
Lessens the effect as well.
So like...
People who are lactose intolerant.
Will be able to drink banana milk.
And strawberry milk.
And that's why they like...
Had a lot of that.
Because they want to encourage people to drink milk more.
To like...
Buy milk more.
So that's why they did that.
I thought it was very interesting.
Uh...
I thought that is incredibly interesting history.
Anyway guys...
Don't...
Don't fucking build up your immunity to allergy.
Like...
I mean like...
Do what your doctors tells you.
Don't listen to medical advice.
From anatomy girl that about to shoot...
Uh...
A historical figures ball.
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA For the celebrate Thanksgiving.
So like...
I...
Listen don't take medical advice from her one, but it's funny I see people post two balls, but a lot of people forget it's one ball
Anyway, um, no need to give a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm 99% all lactose intolerant people stop Stops, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you 100 thank you for the super chatting.
Thank you.
I'm training for my lactose tolerant right now Which means luck doki
Nexie they give us super chat.
Thank you.
I know several Asian dragoons I'm jealous of you.
Thank you a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you You might be wake up in the middle of REM cycle, which is why you feel messed up Look up REM cycles.
You can min max not.
Yeah, I know.
I know like the REM cycle shit I think no matter what I'm still gonna fuck it up So like I'm just trying to see like maybe I can train my body to forget about the REM cycle
Just be okay before like my body would be like you have a Stream I'd like this time just don't care about the REM
Maybe just be okay Doki, just... just be okay.
Alright, anyway, another life update.
Okay, I wrote some stuff regarding life updates.
For those who don't know...
EA slash Apex...
is officially sponsoring...
the prize pool for the Doki X Oversight Apex Custom!
Yay!
Oh my gosh, why am I still aimbotting?
Anyway, oh wait, no, I should be aimbotting.
I'm literally sniping.
Anyway, so it's official official now.
And oh my gosh, I want to say huge shout out to Tempo for doing all the paperwork for it.
It was like a very fast job.
Like we had to like figure everything out really really fast.
So like huge shout out to the devs, to staff at EA slash Apex and also Tempo for doing all the paperwork for it.
And like so like and we're also having physical prizes and also Apex coin packs.
So they were willing... at first, they were suggesting we make the custom $50,000 on top of the $30,000 I was gonna do.
But like I was a bit against it because I was like...
I felt like having a bigger prize pool.
Like it's cool to have a really big prize pool, but I figured like since this is our first custom, I was like, oh, I feel like maybe instead of that we can... I can use the extra funds.
You can do $20,000 and it'll still be $30,000.
I can use the extra funds to improve the foundation of the entire thing.
Because I figured like adding more money might like make it way too competitive than what it is.
So I said that I think it would be better and then with the extra money I save, I would be able to improve the foundations and like because they're very open to working with me and Tempo more in the future in 2025 to set up more Apex customs for the community.
So because of that, I figured like, oh, we could actually make this a real thing.
We could actually make this...
We could actually do more of this and like improve more upon it for next year.
So we were like, yeah, we were asking if that was possible and they were like, yeah, we can do that.
Like, but they would have to give them like what were ideas for next year and stuff like that.
So they were like, okay, if you are actually really open and really willing to post more of these and organize more customs under Apex and under EA, like for EA and everything, we can do that and then like in the future, like next year in 2025, we can do something again in the future with me and Tempo.
So like we went with that route instead.
So I was like really happy.
Negotiations took a while regarding like the details of everything, but I'm really thankful for like EA and like Tempo for like the hard work they've all done.
This custom has been so hard.
So difficult.
So like, I can't wait for Saturday.
So I don't have to worry about it anymore.
But yeah, like we were given an option to make it like 50k, but I was like, I figured it would be better.
Like, especially with this being our first one, like I don't mind if this was like my fucking 10th custom and I was like, oh my god, this is the 10th custom I've ever organized.
Let's make it bigger, like the prize pool bigger, like the all-stars, the all-stars tournament and shit like that.
Then it makes sense to have like 50k, but then I was like, no, this is my first one.
Like, this is the first one I've ever organized under my name and I figured like, oh my gosh, I rather, and that's why I was like heavily pushed for like physical prizes.
And so I was very thankful for Tempo for donating like his physical, the physical Apex items that he owns, like they're all wrapped by the way.
It's all like unopened and everything.
So because I was like pushing for the physical prizes because it like adds more to the fun factor.
And then we told teams like, oh, if you won a physical prize already, if you won the Apex coin packs already, it would be great.
We kindly asked them if they could like give the team below them, like the team that ranked below them, a chance to receive the physical prizes and like the coin packs because like, you know, we want everyone to have a chance to win something basically.
So like, oh, if you haven't won, because like, you know, you know, it like it's like very limited, the physical prizes and I feel like it's, you know, if you win one of the physical prizes, like it's second and third place.
So like if the second third place, they both won those before, then fourth and fifth place can have like, can also have like a physical and the coin pack prizes as well.
And everybody that joins what's 45,000 coin pack worth, it's like $40.
I think it's like 40 to $50.
So and everybody that participates gets a 2100 Apex coin packs.
So everyone that participated will also receive their coin packs as well.
So it's not like so everybody gets something type deal.
So yeah, yeah.
So yeah, we're trying to try to make sure that everybody gets something.
So like, you know, they participated and they received something out of it and said nothing in general.
I also received the pins and stuff.
I just, you know, I want to be thankful for them to giving up their time being here and like, like wanting to, you know, join us and stuff like wanting to play, play and be part of this too.
So it's all like being like encouraging more participations in the future for other events that I host in the future.
Cryptic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look Doki, I get the sentiment, but I think that meant something different when you talk about Thanksgiving ball games.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Party ball.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
I think thank you.
I'm glad EA sponsored for the custom got finalized.
Excited hearing you and EA might work for future customs as well, but hope you can share your work with your team for future events.
Worry that you get over exhausted for every event you organize.
Thank you for the magenta soup, buddy.
Thank you.
Yeah, like after this, I'm definitely, I'm definitely gonna try and delegate my task in the future.
Because like, yeah, just so I could save time for things.
Because organizing this custom has like seeped into my other stuff that I should be doing.
But because I'm already doing all of it myself, my team doesn't know what they need to be done.
So I'm definitely learning a lot from that.
So I'm, I'm definitely gonna try and delegate after.
I know I said that for WrestleTuber, but this time for sure, I'm gonna start delegating for sure this time.
I swear, guys.
I swear.
Um, Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you know you can train yourself to have a polyphasic sleep schedule where you just live on short naps?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You see, I know like some people do that, but I feel like the long-term effects will fuck you up.
Because Tempo does that.
Tempo actually goes with that sleep schedule.
I don't know how the fuck he functions sometimes.
But like, I mean, like, we've seen his streams.
Sometimes he's not okay.
Like the Twitch Rivals I did with him, and he put on the fucking jigsaw mask, and then you're like, oh, I understand now.
But he actually, he actually does that sleep schedule.
So like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, oh yeah, I'll talk more about this after, after the game.
But I was thinking about moving, moving out of Canada.
Like, I was thinking about it today.
Obviously, it's like, I'm not just gonna fucking just suddenly leave the country.
But like, the doctor issue, the fucking doctor shortage, like, actually fucked me up.
Like, I was like, I can't, I was thinking about it.
I was like, I can't believe I had to choose between flying to America to see a doctor, or waiting six plus hours to, for a doctor to potentially see me.
So like, I, I, that was like my limit.
That was literally my limit.
So I was like, oh my god, because it doesn't matter about the money to see a doctor.
They still won't see me, because we don't have enough doctors.
Because apparently, um, a lot of doctors here in the West Coast, they like, they just leave, or they don't do their practice, they don't practice medicine here.
Like, I just, so that's why I was like, people were like, oh, but in the next few years, it'll be different.
Because like, goodbye Trudeau.
But, but like, how would you know?
I can't take a chance on maybe it'll be different.
Like, I can't take that chance.
How would we know?
Like, I have to wait like maybe five plus years to see if it actually changes.
So, so like, because it's not gonna change right away, guys.
Like, it's not gonna change right away.
Like, it's not like, like Trudeau's gone and then Trudeau just be like, by the way, here's like all the doctors you've ever wanted.
It doesn't happen in a year.
I don't even know when, when, when it's gonna come to us.
So, that's why I was like, I was like, he was, he kept all the doctors locked up in the East Coast and now, now that he leaves, they're free now.
Now, they can come back to West Coast.
He locked them all on East Coast.
That's why we didn't have any doctors.
But yeah, like obviously, like I'm not gonna suddenly move out.
I started thinking about it like today because I was like talking to my Canadian friends and we were like, oh my god, it's terrible.
I was like thinking about it because I was just like, but obviously I can't, I also have to renew my passport too.
My passport expires next month and I was like Googling how to renew my passport because the last time I, I'm a very sheltered child, but last time I, I, what about East Coast?
I will never touch, I'm sorry.
I've always been a West Coast child.
I will never cross the line.
West Coast, best coast.
What the fuck she ate?
No, it's not that.
It's just the fact that like, I'll always be a West Coast, a West Coast child.
I'm okay with visiting East Coast, but I can't, I can't, I can't leave.
Leave the West.
I can't guys, I've been raised up with West Coast ping.
This is why you don't deserve the doctors.
This is why all the doctors are on the East instead of the West.
But yes, anyway, so, so, oh my gosh, where was I?
You say why you have no doctors.
But I was just like trying to, I was trying to figure out like what to basically like, what to like, basically like what to do because I'm like, how the fuck do you get a passport renewed?
And you guys didn't know apparently there's the strike that's still going on the Canadian post-strike.
This is like, this is how fucked up our country is right now.
We don't, we can't receive mail.
And like the recent updates is that, um, based, it's like if your US post office fucking closed down, so like update in Canada are, they're still on strike.
So we still can't receive mail right now and like so and then apparently we might not even get mail back until 2025 because it's already passed the deadline for like Christmas packages.
Because if you ever ship things to receive things in time for Christmas, there's a specific day for like when you should send out your packages so you can receive them in time for Christmas.
We're past the deadline now.
So people who sent via Canadian post can't receive their Christmas presents because of it.
Yeah, so because of that, there's like issues with passports too.
So a lot of people have to, for us in Canada, to renew your passport.
We either do it by mail, which is not an option anymore, or we do it like pickup.
So like it's even harder to get your passport renewed, which scares me because like my passport expires, um, next month.
Um, but it's like before, it's like after the concert.
So that's the best part.
It's after the concert, but it's still scares me though.
Because we have to do like pickup.
So instead we don't have the mail option.
So I have to go there in person, but I was reading it up and you can't book appointments.
You have to get lucky.
Like that's, you have to get lucky to be able to renew your passport in like person without an appointment because all appointments are fully booked.
So you have to arrive there at like, at like at opening hours and just like make sure to God that they let you get it done today and you can wait until like hours just to be sure.
It's a passport.
Gotcha.
But it's even worse though.
It's even worse because we can't have mail in option and because we don't have mail in option.
There's gonna be a lot of people that's gonna be there to pick up their passport.
So it's gonna be more people that's trying to pick it up.
There's no online scheduling.
Every appointment option is fully booked months in advance.
So you have to go there like and gotcha and see if you can get your passport renewed.
So I'm gonna do that on like a Monday or something.
So that's another reason why, bro like, if Canada Post goes on strike again, I can't.
Like I can't believe it got so bad that like when people are even gonna get Christmas presents.
Like what the fuck?
I can't believe we're at that point.
They chose like the perfect time to go on strike, but they still haven't got their way yet.
I can't believe we're still arguing with Canada Post.
Why are we still arguing with them?
It's been a fucking month plus now.
Sorry kids.
No, sorry kids.
Santa Elza went on strike.
It's not just West Coast.
It's the entire Canada.
You can't blame West Coast for this.
All of Canada is suffering.
It's not our fault.
This time.
This time it's not our fault.
Um, anyway Maco, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sniper Elite 4 Ball Shot mission sponsored by MASC.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Potato Radio!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Healthcare Concha!
I mean basically, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Neppers!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
All right, let's actually play the game.
Uh, next scene.
Thank you, MagentaSoup.
Ah, thank you, thank you.
West coast, best coast.
So true, exactly.
All right.
Um, all right, sniping time.
Whoa.
Oh, this... this is a different Hertz.
I can... oh, I can tell already.
Okay, give me a...
Give me a sec.
This game is definitely a different Hertz.
From my monitor.
All right.
I need to like close all my tabs related to the passport stuff.
So I can google this again.
I have like 16 tabs open regarding how...
And then I have a tab open about Stephen Harper.
Because I was like, how did he do it?
I was like, oh, if only we knew.
If only we knew.
Like, I'm missing.
Dear Mr. Harper, at least like we never had a can of post-strike.
Wasn't that years ago?
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
We're on headphones.
Wait, do we do full range?
What is this?
Do we do?
But only if we met everybody.
If only we knew.
Okay.
Full range speakers.
Guys, this is how like sad I was today.
I literally looked up Stephen Harper.
Because I was sad.
Because I was like, how do we- How do we do it?
All right.
Oh, yes.
Wait, no.
Of course we want the kill camera.
All right.
Let's see options.
Let's see.
Ultra, low, medium.
Okay, we need medium.
Medium.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay, we gotta figure this out.
At least- Yeah, at least- At least Canada Post like worked under- I had doctors back then.
That's like my- I just was like, I never had an issue with doctors back then.
Uh, putting music down for now.
Okay.
There we go.
All right, cinematic.
Let's see.
Uh, we don't want motion blur, guys.
We don't want motion blur.
Um, so we gotta figure- Okay, low?
That'll work out.
Wait, is it already low?
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Why isn't motion blur on?
Okay, we don't need that.
What the fuck?
Why is this- Oh...
Display setup.
Okay, we got this correct.
Apply this resolution.
Uh...
Tutorial, yes.
Empty lung zoom.
Oh, yes.
I don't see those lungs.
Yeah, motion blur is so gross.
I hate motion blur.
Um...
I don't know.
What else do we have to fix, guys?
Advanced option?
Is there an advanced option?
Is that the one I'm looking at?
Oh, advanced option.
There we go.
Oh, we're not using- Reduce input mouse lag.
We don't want that.
Uh...
Okay.
Oh, shit.
No.
Whoa, wait.
No, wait.
How did ultra graphics made it?
Hahaha!
Whoops.
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, how did ultra graphics made it?
Ultra graphics improved myself.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Toki no.
Okay, guys.
What do we change?
What do we change, guys?
Wait, is aim assist on?
Or is it my- Are you talking about aimbot?
What do we want?
Yeah, don't worry.
We fixed it.
Shadow.
Oh my god.
Why is it like- Wait.
Okay, there we go.
Where the fuck is low?
Okay, shadow reflection detail.
Um, low, low.
This is good.
I don't know if this is good, because like, I'm still lagging a little bit.
Just a little bit though.
Um, but still, it's not great.
Ah, I know that hurts is different too.
When I tab out- When I tab out, it's like, different.
It's like, I- It like- Like, lags a little.
So, I know the- I know the thing, um- The hurts for this is different from the game from my monitor.
Okay, let's see.
Gotta make sure.
Uh, okay.
I'm tabbing back in.
Uh, v-sync is- No.
Do we turn v-sync on, guys?
Do we turn v-sync on?
Oh, it will only make it when we restart the game?
Okay, we'll restart the game.
Okay, we'll restart the game too.
And see if it- Uh, yeah, okay.
We'll restart the game.
Let's turn aim assist off.
And then we'll restart.
Alright.
Give us a sec, we're just gonna restart.
Alright, before we go into our favorite mission- I've never done the mission before.
I've never done it- I've never played Sniper Relief before.
But we all know about the mission.
We all know about the beautiful- The mission that everybody knows.
But I've never played Sniper Relief before.
I thought it'd be like- You know, I thought it'd be like a good- A good way to celebrate Thanksgiving in general.
I mean, I feel like it is a great way to celebrate Thanksgiving.
Um, you know, just to be like- Because it's American Thanksgiving.
I don't even know- If you guys don't know, Canadians already celebrated Canadian Thanksgiving like two months ago.
So this is like nothing to- So it's just a regular- This is just a regular Thursday to us.
But in celebration of, yay, America, I think- Oh yeah, the fake one.
Oh yeah, sorry.
Even though our country is like in flames right now.
Doesn't make us less of a country.
In fact, I'd say it makes us more of a country that we're like not doing okay.
I just feel like us going in flames might mean- If anything, we're more of a country now.
All right.
All right, let's see.
Oh, it's so weird.
It's so like- Um, I mean, it's all right.
But it obviously could be improved.
How low can I go?
How much lower can I go?
No, I'm not.
The doctor shit was actually my breaking point.
So I am not- Like, legitimately, I'm thinking about moving out of Canada because of the doctors.
I'm not okay.
How low can I go?
Too much background stuff is happening.
Oh, yeah, no, I won't be surprised.
All right, let me close more tabs.
Let me close my more- The Doki Bird experience.
We're gonna- We'll get to the game soon, guys.
We'll get to- Don't worry, I'm closing tabs, guys.
I'm doing the bear- I'm closing tabs, guys.
I'm- I'm doing it.
Okay, I'm gonna save this one.
I'm gonna save this link.
And then, I feel like I've closed enough tabs, though.
I think that's enough tabs to close.
That should be enough, right?
All right.
Here we go.
No, I can't close my- All my tabs, because, like, I have to see where- Um, oh, hey, it's better.
Wow, who would have thought?
Guys, I think I had too many tabs.
Guys, I think- Guys, I think I had too many tabs.
All right, let's- Let's do- Prepare for a realistic- Bullet- Ballistic- Deadly- Friendly- Fire- Simplified- You know what?
Let's do hard.
It can't be that difficult, right?
Okay, aggression.
Normal.
Okay, let's stick, like, hard.
And then- It can't be that difficult.
We gotta learn.
We gotta learn how to play this game.
So, default, fine, t-pose, special.
Which was a good- I feel like fine, t-pose, wide.
What's the default?
Default reticle.
Fine crosshair.
I feel like default.
Um, and then- What's a good gun?
What do I have?
We have the springfield, guys.
Okay, and then- This one has less damage.
What's the difference between that?
Oh, the rate of fire.
The carbine.
Wait, the carbine seems good.
Um...
Springfield is decent.
Oh, the other guns.
I have other guns.
I have the Rosmarc.
Rosmarc.
I have the Winchester 1895.
Whoa!
Wait, maybe this one?
Look, it has more green.
Uh, it has more green.
Why do you care about what he looks like?
You should care about what I look like.
LOL
Why are you caring about what he fucking looks like, guys?
All right, guys.
What do we get?
The- Okay, but like...
This has more green, though.
It's not the Winchester.
It's the Winches- But slower rate.
No, the rate of fire is higher.
The rate of fire is higher, though.
It's just a muzzle.
Okay, I'm gonna get this.
Okay, what gun can I do here?
The grease gun.
Ooh, the shotgun.
I feel like if anything I should...
Let's see...
Maybe this one?
And then...
Well rod.
Suppressed.
Oh, they're all suppressed.
Maybe I should get all... Ooh.
Okay, damage, but the rate of fire is high.
Ooh, there's a...
Revolver, but it's not suppressed though.
Maybe this one?
PPSH?
The fuck is a PPSH?
Oh, Pish?
Pish 41?
Is the Pish 41 that good?
All right.
I'll get the Pish 41.
I believe in you guys.
The P- the PP.
All right.
The revolver is cooler.
Okay, all right.
Do I have any skills?
No, I'm just starting.
All right.
Can't be that bad, right?
Okay, I got default skin, mastery skin.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, camouflage!
They can't see me!
Okay, but to be fair, like, it's AI.
I feel like AI can see me.
I feel- Wait, I have explosives.
I have stick grenades.
What else do I need?
I'm not skilled enough, guys.
I don't have enough tokens to unlock these.
Okay, I have stick grenades and med- All right, we're going in.
We're going in!
We can snipe.
Can't be that bad.
It took 45 minutes to start a game, but that's okay.
We'll learn.
We can learn.
I have popcorn too, so it's like an actual movie.
Let's go, Winston!
I know you were incarnated into a monkey!
Oh, shit!
The screen just cut off!
Whoops!
I forgot about that!
Oh, I forgot!
The piglet!
That makes sense.
Whoops!
Okay, you guys can read the subtitles.
It's like, what?
History!
Italia!
Okay.
That was a great movie.
I watched Wicked.
This was an improvement.
Wicked fans, please don't hurt me.
I watched it in 3D, so like, I was not enjoying it as much.
I raised the volume up a little.
I watched it in 3D.
I think I would have actually liked the movie more if I didn't watch it in 3D.
I was eating popcorn.
I have like, caramel popcorn, like sea salt and caramel popcorn on my desk.
Alright.
Let's see.
How do we resume?
Restart.
Resume.
All right, here we go.
British intelligence thinks the Luftwaffe's presence on San Cellini might explain why.
The Royal Navy dispatched a captured Italian freighter, the Orchidea.
to investigate.
She was equipped with the very latest radio interception equipment.
The intelligence she gathered confirmed our worst fears.
I thought it'd be different.
I haven't watched a movie in the theater for like, four plus years.
So I thought it'd be different.
Survivors from the destroyed ships have talked about a new kind of missile.
Radio controlled from the plane that launched them.
These rockets can track our ships with lethal accuracy.
The Orchidea's job was to monitor Luftwaffe radio transmissions and find out what the Germans are up to.
Cookie sounds manly?
Thanks.
I shot that guy's ball and that took his testosterone.
Every ball I shoot, I go stronger.
Now we need to know what the Nazis are planning and how we can stop them.
A member of the Luftwaffe's top brass is a young man, General Tobias Schmidt.
It's no secret Hitler thinks highly of him.
Schmidt would never let himself be taken alive.
He'd never betray his beloved crew.
But he might just be carrying some information with him.
There he goes, gotta practice.
Gotta practice before we get to the big one.
The one big one.
We gotta practice!
Guys, we have to practice before we get to the biggest heist of all time.
I need to find out all I can about the new rocket.
The testy bandito!
You failed.
You failed in NNN.
If you fail NNN, this is what happens.
Remember.
The Toki will come get you.
That's right.
You shouldn't fail.
You shouldn't have failed it.
Alright, 25, 20, and 7.
The Toki is here to enforce.
It's still November!
I'm the nut hunter.
Alright, let's see.
Turn down the overall.
Okay, we'll turn it here.
Alright.
Woah, it still has sensitivities really high.
Let me turn that down.
Guys.
This is a warning to everyone.
It's still November.
How the fuck do I get my gun out?
Give me a sec.
I gotta learn how to take my gun out of the holster.
Does it teach you?
Okay.
Okay, E.
Alright!
No!
I was almost there.
I got the stupid lungs.
Oh, use binoculars?
Oh, tag the enemies?
Okay.
You're next.
Okay, we used the binoculars.
What I just did?
Is there another guy?
Who's hiding from me?
Anybody hiding from me?
Oh, and the pulley.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Oh, you guys are so lucky you have the wall.
You're so lucky.
Fucking, I don't need that shit.
That's fucking rare.
You're lucky the wall is protecting you right now.
So lucky.
Okay, is there anybody?
Anybody here?
No?
Oh my gosh, I need to practice.
Oh, jump the gap?
Oh, that's easy.
Alright, I'm coming for you.
November's not over yet.
No, no.
I'm heading over.
No, I see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't fail.
And then the nuts are gone.
Everyone run!
Okay, what do they have?
What do you have?
It's the adder.
Oh, wait, no.
Give me a sec.
I need to search your body first.
I need to search your body.
Okay.
Can I pick these guns?
Oh, I gotta swap my- No, my gun is already perfect.
Okay.
Alright, off you go.
You know what you did.
Wait, no, you don't get like the- Oh, he is not okay.
She can't- Goodbye!
Alright, get over here.
When you failed the challenge, the ocean must take you now.
Goodbye!
There you go.
See, everything is okay.
I'll make sure like there's nobody here.
Alright, up we go.
Is anybody up here?
No, okay.
Where are they?
There's nobody here, sir.
That's fucked up.
Shouldn't have failed.
You had- It was only 30 days.
You could have- You could have survived 30 days.
I need to make sure those propaganda cameras are destroyed.
Can't have the Nazis spreading their poison.
This one?
Okay, okay.
This is destroyed camera.
Kill officers by any means.
Okay, so I have to kill all of these guys.
Okay.
Only?
Look, if the monks can do it, so can you.
Rest in peace to my nuts.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Return show tutorial.
The fuck does that mean?
Alright, I ain't-
If I had to leave the world, this is the way I have to go.
No, not yet.
You haven't seen the real way.
You haven't seen the actual way you must go.
Is that a camera over there?
No, that's not it.
Okay, if I shoot them, will they know I'm here?
Okay, if I shoot them from here...
Will they know?
Oh shit, what's this?
No, that's less damage.
Will they know if I shoot them from here?
No, they won't.
Will they?
Right here.
Noises and non-lethal shots can help the enemy triangulate your location.
If this happens too much or the enemy gets a visual- I MISSED!
Whereas a ghost image will appear in the environment.
Are useful tools showing?
How did I miss?
God, this is why I needed to practice.
I got a man down.
Oh, he can't move.
I didn't miss.
Oh, I didn't miss.
You get this though.
Wait, how did I miss that?
Okay.
That has to be a- How is that not a hit?
Does he know?
There's no way he knows.
There's no way.
There's no way- Oh my god, he knows.
THERE'S- OH SHIT!
THERE'S BULLET DROP!
GUYS, DID YOU GUYS KNOW- DID YOU GUYS KNOW THERE'S BULLET DROP?
What's the bullet drop?
Right here?
WHAT IS THE BULLET DROP?
Oh my god, I don't know what the bullet drop is.
I don't know.
I don't- I- I don't know.
I don't know what the bullet drop is.
Where is it?
Is it here?
It's-
It's too real.
HOW IS THAT NOT HIT?
THERE'S WINDS!
There's wind.
Oh my god.
WHAT'S THE WIND?
Okay.
I figured out the wind.
I- I- I CAN'T BELIEVE IT!
I- Oh my god.
We figured it out.
We figured out the wind shot.
Oh my god.
There we go.
The fucking wind.
Okay, that's fine.
There we go.
Oh my god, where did I shot that?
Nice.
There we go.
It was worth it.
OH SHIT!
There we go.
That's fine.
I didn't see that guy.
It's fine.
Where's the last guy?
He's gonna regret that.
He's gonna regret that!
Oh!
Headshot.
There we go.
I figured out the lungs.
I figured it out.
There we go, guys.
I figured it out, everybody.
It took us like...
Trial and error.
But I accounted for bullet drop and the stupid wind.
Oh fuck!
Oh!
Give me a sec!
I wasn't looking at the map!
No!
I didn't look at the map!
I downloaded the wind!
But it didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
I didn't realize there were people in the tunnel.
Alright.
Okay, bring down...
Sound effects a little bit.
Okay, I'll bring that down.
Sound effects...
And then...
Huh?
Okay, there we go.
Don't worry.
I figured...
Oh shit.
There we go.
See, look at that.
There we go, look at that.
Wait, you're still alive?
There we go.
Easy.
Fucking easy.
There we go.
I told you, it's so easy.
You'll never know.
I don't need the assignment.
Alright.
We gotta practice.
We gotta still practice.
Don't worry.
We can still practice.
I mean, this was...
Look!
I didn't realize the wind existed!
I forgot!
Guys...
All the practice I had was simulation.
I didn't realize the wind existed.
How do I show tutorial?
Give me my tutorial back!
Where did it go?
Alright, now...
Now it's easy.
I discovered the wind.
Oh my god, they don't know I'm here.
There's no way they know I'm here.
There's no way.
There he is.
How did they know?
How did he know?
That's fucking right.
Oh shit!
Sorry.
I left him.
Now I have time.
There we go.
I still have time.
What the fuck?
Who shot me?
Wait, behind me.
Oh my god, behind me.
How do I heal?
How did I heal?
Guys, how do I heal?
I lost my tutorial.
Where is he?
There's so many people.
I'm a little...
They know I'm here.
How do I use my medkit, guys?
Just walk.
You're right, I can just walk it off.
There's so many people.
This is bad.
This is a little bad.
This is really bad.
Oh, I shot him in the liver though.
I don't know how to use my medkit.
I'm back here!
Oh, I...
My sniper was way too loud.
I gotta run.
Okay.
Maybe they'll have stuff for me.
Okay, I gotta keep running.
I gotta keep running.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
I was fucking around way too much.
If I just hide, they won't know I'm here.
They won't know I'm here.
How would they know I'm here?
How would they know?
See, they don't know.
They're so confused.
Like, where are they going?
They don't know.
I'm safe.
They're so stupid.
Look at that.
I'm stealthing, guys.
Run, run, run.
Stay in this bush.
They don't know.
I'm part of the foolish.
I'm part of it.
See?
Oh, I'm safe!
I'm so safe.
Look at that.
I did it.
I'm pressing return, but it won't give me my tutorial back.
Please.
I just want my tutorial back.
Where did it go?
Okay.
Where did my tutorial go?
Okay, we're gonna have to...
We have to go here.
Alright.
My bush worked.
Okay.
Guys, don't worry.
My bush worked.
I still don't know how to heal.
Okay.
See?
They said I'm dead.
Is there anything over here?
What's that?
There's something over here.
That might be a good thing.
Alright.
Did I do it?
That's you.
That's what happens if you fail November.
That's right.
This is my message to all of you.
You have three more days.
This is...
Let's go.
No.
No nuts November.
Three more days.
Stay strong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Three more days.
What are you gonna do?
Pick him up?
I'm gonna shoot him from here.
Come on.
Wait, what?
From where?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I gotta kill him though.
There we go.
That's right.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay, we leave.
We got what we wanted.
We leave.
We'll be fine.
We will not be fine.
They won't know I'm down here though.
They won't know.
They won't know I'm here.
We got the shot we wanted.
That's all that matters.
Three more days.
You guys can do it, guys.
Stay strong.
Everybody.
Okay, let's see.
Turn down that.
And then turn music down a little bit.
No.
Alright, we just gotta wait a little.
But I'm weak.
I'm weak.
Three more days to fail three more times.
Okay.
There's no way.
There's no way they go over here, right?
A moment of silence for the Nesticles in the chat.
And for the people who failed.
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
This is just practice.
Okay, nice.
See?
Easy.
It's not that bad.
Okay, we gotta kill four officers over here.
And then...
Oh, we just gotta kill this guy.
This is the most important guy.
Okay.
We need to find him.
Nope, no you don't.
I'm gonna go into hiding.
Go into the gooner cave.
Okay, what's this?
Wait, what is this area?
Is this like a hiding spot?
What is this?
Oh, it's like a little hiding spot.
Is there anything here?
Is there any extra loot here?
Is this the cave?
That cave can't save you.
I found the cave.
They're above me.
Okay, we gotta go here.
I hear them, but I don't know where they are.
How do I get back up?
Am I stuck here?
How the fuck do I get outta here?
Where's my pistol?
Oh, there's a guy right here.
There's a guy right here.
Where did he go?
He was literally right here.
I literally saw him walking here.
Wait, what?
No, I swear there was a guy right in front of us.
Oh my god, where is he?
Okay, I gotta figure out how to get out of this fucking cave.
This fucking area.
What?
Where the fuck?
Nice.
That's how you...
He didn't fail, I just didn't like him.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I just didn't like him.
He was wrong.
Wrong time, wrong place.
Maybe I can go up here?
Is there anything here?
No, it's just a cave.
But what about...
Cause look him in the eye and tell him...
And then go for the shot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anybody here?
Oh my god, I feel like...
It's so paranoia.
Because I don't know where they are.
Oh, he's here.
Nice.
The wind can't stop me.
I'm too close for the wind.
That's fucking right.
Stupid wind.
Who invented wind anyway?
Can't stop me.
That's right, give me your shit.
Nobody will remember who you are.
No one will remember you.
Nobody.
Get out.
Oh, okay.
I mean...
Now you look very pretty on that rock.
Suppressed ammo allow you to fire your weapon silently.
Oh, wait.
I can change it with the radical...
Wait, how?
How do I change it?
You can't say that.
I don't know how to change it.
Okay, we're gonna...
You can change...
How do I change it?
Alright.
Scope, reload, shoulder aim.
Shoulder aim, toggle, increase...
I can increase the scope range?
Okay.
Traverse, pick up weapon, defuse.
Q.
Okay, it's Q.
Radio, menu.
Okay, Q.
Toggle, select item, medkit.
Okay, 6.
Select...
What the fuck am I gonna do with a rock?
Alright, Q.
Okay.
Oh my god, I have rocks?
Regular ammo.
Do I even have suppressed?
Oh, I do!
Wait, I wasn't using suppressed this entire time?
I can fucking throw a rock at somebody.
Wait, where's the rock?
How do I get the rock out?
How do I?
Wait, how do I get the rock out?
Select rock.
Oh, it's 7.
I put on my glasses, by the way.
Wait, I don't have a rock.
It's F?
Oh!
There we go, I figured it out.
Yeah, I assume it is.
Because it makes it so that...
There we go.
That's easy.
That part is easy.
Because they're so close, so I don't have to worry about...
Oh, what the fuck?
No.
Oh no, no, no!
How are you still alive?
Oh no, oh no, oh no, he's still alive!
He's still alive!
How are you still alive?
No, we gotta run.
We gotta run.
And I didn't expect him to live.
Okay, we got...
I don't remember how to heal.
Guys, which one was heal?
Guys, I don't remember how to heal.
Is it 6?
It's not 6!
I can't get my heals out!
Oh my god, it's not 6.
It won't let me heal.
It won't let me heal!
Please.
Please, this is all I ask.
Oh, 6 and then F.
Oh, and then F, okay.
Okay, I'm okay now.
You know what?
Fuck this one guy in particular, though.
Oh, he can't move!
Oh my god, I shot his spine!
You think he's gonna help you?
You can't walk!
You had 3 days.
What the fuck?
He had 3 days.
I'm going the wrong way.
It's like, oh my god, it's all the way there?
Alright, let's test out fall damage.
Okay, the game won't let me test out fall.
Even the game was like...
It was like, we're not testing out fall.
Oh, unless...
Yeah!
No fall damage!
Let's go.
Okay, we have to go this way and then across the bridge.
There's a lot of people on that bridge!
Woah, okay.
Do we save?
Oh yeah, we should.
Oh, I didn't realize you can save.
Okay, this is gonna be...
Okay, I don't think this has anything to do with November anymore.
You don't know that.
Oh, I don't know what you're talking about.
What do you mean?
No?
No, what are you talking about?
I definitely heard something.
No?
Nope.
There was nothing here.
Just a regular bush.
Nothing here.
Nothing suspicious at all, guys.
Just a win, exactly!
It's just a win, everybody!
It's just a win!
Look, he like, tripped.
It's just his allergies.
Oh my god.
Silly Tommy.
Did you get a...
Look, he's allergic to poison.
He's allergic to poison ivy, guys.
Guys, he's allergic to poison ivy.
He's just going through like a little episode.
That's really it.
Why is everybody freaking out?
Guys, stop freaking out, everyone!
Stop freaking out.
See?
Nothing here!
I told you guys!
There was nothing here!
I told you all, there was nothing to worry about.
Okay, we'll do this and then we'll kill Schmidt.
Alright.
He was weak.
Oh, this is good.
When there's a plane, I can make sound.
It's okay, nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry about.
Okay, but wouldn't it be funny if I...
That's pretty funny.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he also had an allergic reaction!
Oh my god!
This poison ivy is so intense.
This...
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
This poison ivy, man.
Someone's gotta check this bush out.
They got some Bob B.
Somebody help him!
He's allergic to bee stings!
Oh no, the grass.
Oh no!
We have a bee problem!
We have a bee problem here!
In this base!
Oh my god, won't somebody think about the bees?
Did I get him?
Guys, I don't think I got him.
I wanna loot him so bad, but they're looking at me over there!
Oh my god, please just let me loot this body!
Okay.
It's fine.
If I push out, if I just shoot me over...
They don't see me.
Okay, they definitely might see me now.
Okay.
He's alive!
It's a Christmas miracle!
Okay, I got him.
Oh my god!
He made it!
Steve made it!
Silly Steve!
What are you doing on the barbed wire, Steve?
You're such a silly man.
He's just resting.
Alright, so I can cross the bridge now, right?
That should be safe to cross the bridge now.
Like, surely...
Surely the bush has killed enough.
I'm pretty sure the bush has done enough.
Taking a nap on the job, Steve.
You're so silly.
Oh!
Nice.
We got an officer.
What happens?
Inspire soldiers to get out, cover, and track you down?
Oh shit!
That's right!
You lost your brain!
What would the soldiers do?
Plastic, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you!
Look, that was his.
You know what that hat was.
Yeah, that was...
You know exactly.
You know exactly what that had on.
This is my message to all of you.
Three more days.
You guys can do it.
It's just three more days.
Alright, alright.
I killed Nazis.
One of them is over here.
Where are they?
Okay, well I'll go this way then.
I'm gonna go this way and hide in the bush.
My favorite bush.
I love these bushes.
Where could they be?
I need like...
Look for weak points in the environment and a well-placed shot may cause a reaction.
Oh wait, really?
Where?
Where did I kill him?
Wait, where did I kill him though?
What?!
There we go.
Okay, alright.
I fucking hate Blitz.
I hate the win.
I fucking hate the win.
Alright, get over here.
Where's his body?
Sometimes I'm like, where did I kill the- oh, there they are.
Alright, I need you.
I need ammo really badly.
God damn it.
That must have been the win.
Where the fuck is- I need to kill two former officers, but where are they?
Oh my god.
That should be the drop-off, right?
Where is it going?
There was nobody there.
But it was cool though.
Guys it looked cool.
Guys, guys it looked cool though.
I got the shot though.
Guys, but I got the shot.
It looked really cool.
There we go.
It looked really fucking cool.
Okay, he's like next to a bush.
Thank god.
I'm trying to find another officer.
I'll be able to kill four.
I don't have a lot of ammo left.
Infantry, infantry.
The fuck?
Where are you?
Oh!
I thought when they said four, zero- Oh, I'm so stupid.
This is where the other officers are.
I thought when it was like one out of four, I thought it meant like there's four in this one area.
Okay, I can leave.
I can go.
Oh, that's what they mean.
Okay, I'm running out of ammo.
I'm gonna start.
Blazing.
All right, this is it.
I'm gonna try and find other snipers to kill.
It's over.
I'm done sniping.
Where are you?
Do you have ammo?
I really need ammo.
I think I've grabbed all I can.
Did you give me any?
God damn it.
All right.
You're right, I can just melee.
I'm done.
Oh, search buildings?
Oh, you're right, team.
I actually- There might be some in the building.
I'm out of- Oh, wait, am I just out of suppress?
Oh, that's true.
I can just be out of suppressed ammo.
What's this?
Okay, I got letters.
I got pistol ammo.
Nobody lives here anymore.
I wonder what happened.
Huh.
I wonder what happened to all the- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I wonder what happened to all the people here.
That's so weird, guys.
It's like a ghost town.
I wonder if it's allergy season.
The poison- Yeah, it could've been- I heard poison ivy is really bad.
At this time of the year.
Oh, we have a TNT!
Wait, I want to use it.
I wonder if I can do like Ash does and just throw a TNT in the air and just shoot it.
That would be cool.
Okay, we're just gonna kill General Schmidt.
Alright, Schmitty.
I'm coming over, Schmitty.
Got a lot of practice, Schmitty.
Okay, wait, let's- Oh yeah, I definitely have enough.
Wait, but I want to use TNT.
What happens if I-
TNT is powerful.
It needs to receive damage to throw for precise or simply drop spaces.
There's no need to trigger- Oh, let's do it.
Wait, I have an idea.
Oh, I have a funny idea.
I have a really funny idea.
Okay, watch this, guys.
I need to get to the bush, though.
Watch this.
I have a really funny idea.
Wait, where is it?
Okay, and then...
Wait, where did my TNT go?
That's not the idea I had, but like...
I can't find the TNT.
I don't know where it is.
Okay, it works if I'm up here.
Okay, okay.
This is a really funny idea, but I can get it to work if I'm up here, though.
Is it over here?
Okay, guys, watch this.
It's gonna be so funny.
Okay.
Come on, get over here.
Come on!
Wait, did he see me?
Oh!
I
have a tree!
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
My funny idea!
My so funny idea!
No!
Funny idea!
Okay.
No, they saw me!
Oh, no.
No, my TNT!
Okay.
Okay, I got one of them out of the way.
They don't know.
Get up!
Get up, soldier!
Okay.
Wait, he still sees me?
Where?
Oh, thank God.
Next shot.
He's still on me.
Okay, but will he see me if I'm here?
Oh, my God, he does!
Wait!
Okay, but what if I'm here?
Okay, he doesn't know.
I'm so far away.
There's no way.
There's no way they know I'm here now.
I'm in this bush.
That's a different bush, guys.
Oh, shit!
Guys, he knew.
I don't understand.
I was in a different bush.
Okay, but I'm in this bush now.
I'm in a different bush this time, guys.
He doesn't know.
Guys, I'm in a different bush!
It's different!
Okay, but like...
Look at this funny idea, though.
Okay, watch this funny idea.
Where did I throw it?
Wait, where did I throw it?
Wait, where is it?
Where did I throw it?
Where is it?
Wait, where's my...
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Okay, watch this, guys.
It's gonna be so funny.
Watch this.
Wait, he lives?
Look at that.
That was pretty funny, guys.
Guys, watch this, guys.
Watch this.
I see him right over here.
Yeah?
Oh, whoops.
I thought I shot it!
Okay, but like...
You can't dodge this, though.
There's no way he's gonna dodge this.
There we go, we did it.
I told you, guys!
I told you!
We used up all our...
grenades, but that's okay.
It was all for the funny, guys.
It was all for the funny.
Okay, we already got his stuff.
Oh.
Okay, we did it.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god!
He got flung so far away!
Sir, I need your body.
I need the ammo.
I'm running out.
Okay.
How much do I have from suppress?
I still only have 50.
I think they're starting to build their bush immunity!
No, don't say that!
Don't...
Don't say that, guys!
Nobody is immune to the bush forever!
They can't!
That's the one thing you can't build immunity for!
Oh, hey, Steve's still here.
Hey, Steve!
Having a good time over here?
Guys, I am learning, though.
Like...
Okay!
I am getting better!
I'm figuring this out, boy!
Alright, we gotta kill General Schmidt.
Oh, General Schmidt!
I'm coming over!
I learned a lot today.
Oh, hey!
How did these guys die?
Who killed them?
Who could it be?
I wonder who could have killed these guys.
Okay.
Oh.
That has to be a headshot.
Oh!
Wait, that was Schmidt?
Wait, was that...
Oh!
What the fuck?
What was he doing over there?
Schmitty!
What the fuck were you doing there, Schmitty?
I didn't realize I was Schmitty this entire time!
Oh, shit!
Schmitty just wanted to admire the view!
No, not again!
No!
I killed Schmitty though!
Okay, but what the fuck was he doing?
I did not expect him to be there!
Oh my god, how did they know?
There's no way they know I ran this way though.
Oh, there he is.
They know.
Okay, but there's no way they know I ran this way.
They do.
Okay, but what if I'm here?
Oh, they also do.
Okay, but what if I'm over here?
Guys, how do they keep knowing?
Like, okay, but what if I'm like here?
Oh, they don't know I'm here now.
They don't know, they think I'm over there.
Oh my god, guys!
Guys!
There's a lot of them!
Guys, I'm- I don't think they know I'm in the bush next door.
There's no way they know I'm next door, right?
There's no way!
I can't use the TNT trick!
I don't know where the-
Okay.
Okay, but what if they- What if they look at this TNT right there?
What if they look at this TNT over here?
Three times the- The bush claims another.
The bush claims another.
Hahaha!
See, and this is why you wear a helmet, guys.
This is exactly why you wear- Okay, but what if like- Okay, wait, I got an idea.
Come over here.
That's right.
No, you One, two...
Oh, they're coming.
They're coming over.
They're- oh, that's two.
That's two.
That's three.
Wait, four, three.
Come on, get the third guy in here!
Two is fine enough.
That's fine enough for me.
That's- Okay, we did it.
Oh, I almost did it!
I made a little mistake.
I got a little excited.
I got- I got a little excited, guys.
I made a little mistake.
Okay, but like- but like, the bush calls.
The bush calls.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this bush is...
This bush keeps spitting out rocks.
What's going on?
The bush yearns for more.
It yearns for more.
Okay, let's bandage ourselves up.
We got...
The bush thirsts for blood.
Okay, let's get this guy out of the way.
Okay, we're fine now.
All right, we gotta search up Schmitty.
You feed the bush.
Feed the bush.
All right, we gotta loot him.
And then you gotta loot him.
I didn't realize that was J- He's just out in the- I thought that he would be like, I don't know, deeper in the fucking building.
He's just out there admiring.
Okay, if I was a general of, you know, one of the most like, try- like one of the most like, you know, sought after guy who's trying to get assassinated and everything, I would not be standing in the fucking open admiring the view with no one next to him.
Like- I legitimately- I legitimately thought he would be like, deeper in that building.
He was- he was admiring the bush.
He was literally right there.
That was like- that seemed like- that seemed like a different guy.
He was like, what the fuck?
I thought he would be in the building.
What are you doing here?
He heard about the bush.
Safeholds important.
And every- make sure you search important enemies.
You just blow up the safe.
That blast may destroy some- but that's a risk worth taking, right?
What did I got?
All right, we can get the safe too.
He heard about the infamous bush.
He had to come in.
Okay, we can- I feel like we've killed everybody in this house.
I mean, their leader just died because of me.
But where is this guy though?
I think he's inside here.
Huh, how do I get to the safe?
I killed like- like three people.
No, I didn't kill three.
The bush did.
This isn't even a good view over here.
Like, it would make sense if it was looking this way.
What is he looking over here?
And it would make more sense if it was the other way.
How do we go upstairs though?
Oh, he's over there.
I'm just gonna kill this guy.
There we go.
Like, you're literally the last guy alive.
Like, I- Nobody will hear you scream.
No one will hear you scream.
Everyone- all your friends are dead.
Dead.
Okay, this has to be it.
There we go.
All right, nice.
Use code.
Yay, we did it!
Wait, what's this?
Swatch h- swap hdm for luger?
Whoa!
Yeah, but this one's suppressed.
Why would I ever swap that?
Wait, use code doki bird.
Okay, how do I get out?
Did I not win?
Oh, I have to kill all of them?
But I killed the main guy.
Oh, you have to kill all of them.
I thought like if you kill the main guy, it's over.
Okay.
That's right.
Destroy.
Destroy the history.
No recordings.
Yeah, I mean it worked for that guy.
It worked for the guy I'm gonna kill next in the next mission.
That's basically how it goes.
Did they not surrender?
Like, what happened?
It's usually how it goes!
Okay, you guys want me to try the- oh, let's try it.
Okay, let's try it.
Future generations must not know this strat.
To be fair, people thought like he didn't actually die.
People were like, there's no way.
Damn, I thought he was supposed to be a god.
To be fair, yeah, like nobody believed.
Nobody believed he actually died- died.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
We gotta kill the officer in this area.
Wouldn't it be funny if we find him right away too?
Oh, this one's difficult.
Wait, there's no bushes here!
Oh, this is more difficult.
How am I supposed to kill that one guy?
With all my bushes!
Oh, this is bad.
I don't know how to play this game without foilage.
What do I do when there's no nature to help me?
What?!
My one bush!
Hahaha!
Me and my one bush.
No, he's blowing the whistle!
He's blowing the whistle, guys!
He's blowing the whistle!
What do I do?!
Okay, maybe he'll come closer.
The bush hungers.
The bush- oh, fuck.
Okay, um...
Um, how do I do this?
Press hold.
Oh, wait, fuck.
Okay, I can't- I have to set the mine.
Okay, this is bad.
Okay.
Trip mine.
Okay, what about teller mine?
Oh, okay.
There's no way I can die from here.
Wait.
There's so many there.
There's so- There's no way!
There's literally like 500 of them next to this!
Just walk over!
Yeah, I was.
I was over there.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I was over there.
Famous last words.
Bro, he's just blowing on his whistle like a nerd.
All right.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, they're scared.
I can't get out of the bush because I'm one guy- Oh, what?!
I'm- Are you serious?!
Okay, we do this again.
I literally pressed D!
I pressed D, I swear to god!
I swear to god!
He killed- He did it!
He did it!
He finally defeated the evil!
He finally did it.
Is it not E for the knife?!
What the fuck was it?!
Okay, now I'm mad.
What is knife?
I did E!
I got knife!
Push that shot.
The funny mustache.
The bush took me instead.
No!
E is for- Why can't I melee?!
What the fuck is melee then?!
What the fuck is- Get in the- Get in!
Get in here.
Please, just die to my- What's regular melee?!
The evil has been defeated.
Please, there's so many.
Please, is nobody thinking this is suspicious at all?
Is- Does no one- Does no one find this weird?
There's no one find this weird that there's a fuck- There's 2,000 rocks coming out of that.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, they saw me?
Guys, they saw me.
Because I think they saw me.
Guys, I think they saw me in this bush.
Like, I'm not sure yet.
AHH!
NOOO!
Guys, they don't know.
This is like- Nobody wanted to go near my dynamite.
I don't know what- No, I got it.
I got an idea.
Oh, I have enough suppressed ammo now.
Okay.
Wait, this is it.
Oh, and then he ran off.
That's fine.
Maybe I can do the rock thing again.
Guys, look at all these- Look at all these- Look at this dynamite.
It's just sitting there.
Look at all that.
Come on!
It's gonna be so fun.
Please, anybody.
Oh, thank god.
Are you serious?
There we go.
I had to throw his bullet drop off.
Nice.
Oh, that looks nasty.
Oh, at least I got- Oh, I hit him in the eye too?
Please, I just- I need one.
Please, just one guy show up, please.
Wait.
Okay.
He ran away?
Why must you run away?
What are you afraid of?
Oh my god, I want to get out of this.
I can't get out.
Why do they keep running away?
Look at all these rocks.
Maybe he runs away.
I can pick this up now.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Please!
I just- Okay, we could do this again.
Please, I- Leave me alone.
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
I'm not- I'm not fucking around no more.
Wait, my god!
What?
What happened?
What killed me?
What?
Nuff.
What actually killed me?
He fucking helped- Oh, oh, I'm gonna- Okay, now I'm actually not fucking around no more.
Where's that gonna go?
Okay, it went that way.
Okay.
All right.
I have an idea.
Guys, guys, I figured this out, guys.
Okay, I mean that works too.
Okay, but what if like-
Okay, okay, okay, this works!
This works!
Guys, I figured it out!
Oh, shit!
I can do it again.
Yes!
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh, shit!
Wait, we gotta defuse it.
I
did so much!
Oh, god!
Get out!
It's okay, we're fine.
We're so healthy.
Where is he?
There we go.
Oh my god, look at my- Look at all these bodies!
We did it!
Yay!
Oh my god, we did it, everybody!
It's just that easy!
Look at that!
All right, we just gotta get all our fucking loot back.
See, guys?
See, it wasn't that hard.
Guys, it wasn't that difficult, guys.
All it took was five mines.
And then you two can succeed.
Jesus, I turned into minesweeper.
It was- it was not sniper elite anymore.
It was a minesweeper time.
Oh, they never learn!
They just never learn, what can I say?
They could have learned, they just didn't.
Mines elite four.
I should have done the same.
I was in a corner!
What else was I supposed to do in that corner?
Okay, one- two more.
Two more.
Oh, you're next.
I see you up there.
You're fucking next, I'm heading over.
I'm fucking heading over right now.
That's right!
I'm getting over!
All right.
Okay, let's see if I get to this.
Oh, there's more bushes here, thank fucking god.
Okay, that's good.
Oh lord, she's coming over.
Am I using suppressed?
I am.
Wait, what?
There we go.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Come on.
Everything is not fine anymore.
Guys, guys!
Everything is fine anymore.
Oh, it's fine.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Push.
Wait, wait,
wait.
I've learned.
I've learned the strat.
You have to go right here.
You have to cross right here.
That's where my triangle was.
That's where it was.
Come on, touch the triangle.
You know you want to touch the triangle.
Oh, I see you, officer.
You're right over here.
Wait, did they shot my trap?
They shot it?
How did they know?
Dude, I don't understand.
Clever girl.
Oh, but the officer, you're right over here.
You're right over here, officer.
I know you are.
You're right over here.
I know I could have done a takedown, but this was easier.
See?
Still.
Oh, I could have shot this, but then I'd die too.
All right, let's practice.
You're- WHOA!
Oh, shit.
No scope.
All right.
Okay, wait, watch this, guys.
I have to get closer.
Watch this, though.
Wait, okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Okay, but watch this shot.
Right here.
Okay, okay, watch this shot right here.
WHOA!
Wait, where is he?
All right,
this is a you tried award.
Insane!
Guys, did you- did you see that?
Oh my god!
$3.60 scope!
I told you!
I got him!
$3.60 scope!
Okay, where the fuck do I get over here?
We gotta go this way.
That was a $3.60 no scope right there.
That's right, FPS gamer of- okay, not FPS of VTuber of the year right there.
That should have been my clip.
How the fuck, dude?
It's all fenced up!
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh, it's this way.
It's fine.
We're just gonna casually walk over.
Put down the VTuber awards video.
Mike, thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm trying to figure out how to get out of here.
I think this is the worst part, just like trying to navigate this entire area.
The navi- I just- how- it's down there?!
How the fuck do I get down there?
Okay, I need to figure out how to get down there, guys.
Okay, we go from here and then we have to travel across- I have to travel across all those bases?!
All right.
It's a task I'm willing to take.
I don't have a parachute.
Dude, fuck this.
I'll find him.
Where are you?
Okay, there's him.
I'll find him.
Where is he?
I'm not going down there, guys.
I'm just gonna find him.
No, that's just babies.
Where is the main guy?
Okay, I need to find the main man.
Yeah, I have a better sight here.
You know what?
Shit.
All right, where is he?
Oh, there you are.
Are
you serious?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, no, he saw me.
Who's shooting me?
Are you fucking- ah!
Okay, bullet trap.
There we go.
Oh my god, the stupid bullet trap.
There we go, we did it.
We fucking did it.
We got the high ground shot.
Stupid wind.
All right, we gotta figure out how to get out of here.
Escape from the- ah, fucking- oh shit.
Okay, I'm here.
All right.
Yeah, I'll figure out how to get to me first.
God, there we go.
I did- okay, I'm gonna wait for that one guy to show up before anything.
Uh...
Yeah, fuck, I'm gonna wait for that one guy to show up.
I know you guys want to come over here.
Before I get out of the bush.
Wait, can I escape down there too?
Oh, I can!
Oh my god, to go downstairs anyway!
What the- I just want to make sure I don't get caught by some fucker.
I want to be sure I'm safe.
Yeah, there is one down there.
I have to go down there anyway.
This sucks.
Where are they?
The rock- the bush is calling.
The bush is calling.
The bush is calling for you!
Where are you?
The bush hungers!
I know you're here!
My god, where is that one guy?
Oh shit!
That's where he is.
Oh, yo.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
No food for you.
Don't underestimate me.
Oh shit!
I'm sorry!
Yo, yo.
I'm just gonna make sure they are all dead.
I don't think my ears are working anymore.
Ping, ping!
Okay, there we go.
I know there's one more guy.
Oh, they all ran away.
That's good.
Am I safe now?
Can I go home?
Can I go home now?
Can I move from this spot?
Am I allowed to move?
Please, I just want to leave.
We have achieved one.
I can't help myself.
I keep headshotting.
I couldn't help it, guys.
The gamer in me keeps wanting to headshot.
And also, not a lot of people failed November, so like, they were safe.
They got lucky.
Only one guy failed November.
Oh my god.
Hey, I said ballshot mission.
I said ballshot missions.
Please let me go!
I wanna leave the bush!
Oh my god, I accidentally used my bandage.
Fuck.
I was trying to throw rocks.
Let me leave!
Oh my god, please.
I legit, I just wanna...
I'm gonna shoot this guy.
Okay, wait a minute.
Okay, okay, to be fair, that guy was asking for it right there.
He was, he was like, okay, okay, you can't say he was not asking for that.
You did not see him?
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
God, how do I get down?
Eh.
There's like two over there.
I don't know where, so I'm just gonna...
Oh my god, I can't run from there.
He literally showed his butt.
Guys, can you really blame me?
He showed his butt to me and I was like, whoa.
Gotta take that shot.
Okay, I can do this.
Watch this.
Three, two, one.
Oh my god!
What?
Okay, okay, I had no angle.
There we go.
Oh, wait, what?
He lives?
He lives again?
There we... what?
The camera got... that's not fair!
I got fucked over
by...
the camera!
It was the camera's fault.
I could've been like...
That helmet protects the shit out of him.
Holy shit, the strongest helmet in fucking Germany.
All right.
All right, we finally can finally get to walk downstairs.
Oh my god, that was the hardest way to get downstairs possible.
And those helmets are actually bulletproof.
It's like helmet guys, always wear your helmet.
It works.
All right, I think... I think... oh wait, yeah, I forgot we're in Italy.
We're in Italy.
Well, I have to kill like Nazis.
So of course like my mind went to Germany.
All right, I think I killed everybody here so we can leave.
Hello.
Oh, this is the guy I killed.
All right, nice.
All right, get over here.
I'm taking you with me.
You're gonna be my trophy.
So they'll know I did it.
They'll know I'm bringing you with me.
Come on.
I'll get a heart attack if I...
like, sprint too much.
You're coming with me.
Oh my god, we did it!
We finally did it!
Oh, we don't care about the camera.
The camera does not matter to me.
I swear...
Schmidt was literally the easiest one.
Schmitty...
Schmitty was the... was the easiest general of all of them.
Because he literally just walked outside.
And just like let me kill him.
All right, now it's time, chat.
Now... now that I've learned...
It's time.
Schmitty was asking for it.
Damn, this is the moment of truth.
All right.
Here we go.
Yep.
All right.
Is this the loadout we're going for?
Guys, is there a better...
Is there a better loadout?
Should we... is this the one we're going for, chat?
Do we get any other gun?
Do we have...
We have...
Springfield, Carmen...
38...
Carbine, Gerard, Rosmarc, Winchester, Swedish, and Rifle.
Springfield?
Oh my god, everybody's voting for different ways.
Which... oh, M1?
Everyone says... I saw a lot of M1.
Where's M1?
Okay, but we have several M1s though.
The Gerard, we have M1...
Gerard, M1 Carbine...
M1... M1 903 Springfield.
M1 Gerard, this one?
Who are the...
Okay, all right.
And then our other guns is that... do we stay all over this?
Oh, it makes a ping noise!
Oh, wait, that's fun!
Oh, we can buy items now.
Should we buy more?
Suppress rifle.
Oh, we should buy suppress rifle ammo.
Use for quiet air.
Okay, should we buy anything?
Buy mines?
Oh, you're right.
We should.
Holy shit!
Okay, that's fine.
We'll find more mines.
All right, here we go.
All right, we will get our... we will not end until we get the ball shot.
I don't care how long it takes.
We don't end this game until we get the shot.
An island to the north of Crete.
Nothing here but rocks and seabirds.
The shot!
The nazis are determined to use all their units to cut up Red Squadron, which is the main enemy of the Red Army and the NATO base.
Our informant in the German navy says the new base is being built on Sundari.
British intelligence want it neutralized.
That means assassinating Admiral Herman Richter, the base commander.
Any damage I can inflict along the way would be a definite bonus.
Fortunately, our informant has left me some resources in one of the seaforts.
I reckon I might need them.
What happens next could change the course of the war.
I'm not throwing away my shot!
That shot is the only reason why I want to play this game.
We'll practice.
We'll practice on all the other guys here.
Guys, we're gonna practice.
Don't worry.
We'll practice on all the other men before we get to him.
Wait, but where is he?
Admiral Richter?
Okay, where the fuck is he?
I don't see it.
I think this game is- it's like it's steam sale right now.
So it's a hundred percent worth it.
I bought this yesterday during the steam sale.
Look at that.
The Germans have got themselves an impressive operation.
Okay.
Where are the others?
Oh, wait, I can take this shot.
Did it hit that?
No, what the fuck did I hit?
What the fuck?!
What did I hit?
Oh my god, ping.
God, stupid win!
Stupid fucking win got me again.
I hate the win.
I hate the win so much.
What is this?
The Q-E?
Wait, what is it?
What is this thing that I'm doing?
Oh!
Like, what is this thing?
God, it's fine.
There's no win here.
There's no win here!
What's the- a changing- Adjusts the fire range?
Oh!
So like, I can't adjust it though, but what does that do?
God fucking- okay, we can do this.
No!
I still got him though!
Okay, that's fucking right.
I still got him.
Okay, we gotta practice ball shots.
Oh no, they saw me.
No!
It's okay.
We're okay.
I need to practice the ball shot.
Wait, he gets up?
You get up?
What is wrong with you?
Bro, he got up!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh no.
Dude feels no pain.
Like, what is wrong with him?
How do you get up?
This has- this guy has to be-
Okay, that was definitely not 500.
How do I know what the range is?
Like, I'm trying to figure out what the range is.
Oh shit, I hit that.
Adrenaline Park.
Oh, if I mark him with the- There we go.
You do not get up.
All right, guys, I don't know why I'm learning with the Fuhrer with this.
There we go, we're fine now.
Now they don't know.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, now I figured it out.
Now I figured it out.
Now I win this.
Come on, get over here.
Wait, I can go prone?
Wait, no.
Oh, come on.
Oh, he was just right there.
He was right there.
I could have taken the shot.
Where is he going?
I don't know.
I want to take his loot.
I should actually heal though.
I feel like I was- I definitely lost a lot of blood there.
From that.
Okay.
Oh, what?
This Fuhrer.
Where the fuck was he?
That's not near me, right?
I'll be fine, right?
I'll be fine right here.
Oh, he's gonna bleed out.
Don't worry, bro.
I'll finish the job.
How are you still alive?
Okay, now I'll finish the job.
Is that it?
Where's the other guy?
Where was the guy that shot me from 20 miles away?
There you are.
Oh, there you- There you are.
Okay.
I see you.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Sit down.
Sit your fucking ass down.
This one I'll just headshot you.
Ezuki.
The real sniper?
See that again.
The what sniper?
The what?
You mean the guy that's fucking dead?
There he is.
The dead sniper now.
That's fucking right.
Fucking real sniper.
Alright.
There's another bush right there.
They saw me, didn't they?
They saw me.
But did they see me go into- Did they see me go into this bush?
Wait, what?
What was that?
Wait, did they call for reinforcements?
OH SHIT!
OH!
What the
f - I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
It's okay.
See, I lived.
I lived, guys.
I lived.
They got the wrong guy.
There's literally one guy left.
I'm trying to figure out where he is.
Oh, there he is.
I didn't shoot him in the balls.
I shot him in the goddamn liver.
It's not the same.
It's not the same when it's not the balls.
I need to practice!
That's fine, they're all dead now.
Ding!
Oh, shit.
Guys, I fucked up the self part.
Did you guys notice that?
Is it noticeable that I fucked up?
It's okay, we can recover from this!
Guys, we can recover!
We can fix this.
Very easily.
It is fixable!
It is so fixable, chat.
It is so fixable.
We'll be fine.
If you don't know, I'm here.
I can start going inside now.
Okay, watch this.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Watch this.
It's so cool!
We did it!
Nothing else.
We did it, guys.
Did you guys see it?
Oh my god, that jump was insane!
That was an insane jump!
Oh my god, first try too!
She's fucking insane at this game.
First try as well?
How the fuck does she do it?
Where are they going?
Holy shit, how does she do it?
Actually fucking crazy.
There was a guy heading over this way.
Oh my god, where?
Okay, this is safe.
It's safe so far.
Where the fuck are the supplies?
I know there's like several people here too.
Yeah, this is like scary.
It's like, where are they?
Okay, there's two up top.
See?
Nothing happened.
They're like, oh, it was just the wind.
I'm like, yeah, the wind.
See?
They're going back!
They think it's just the wind!
Wait, what?
Oh shit, oops.
Oops.
It was just the wind, guys.
It said 58, that should've hit.
That must've hit.
Oh, there we go, that's what I like to see.
Okay.
Okay, I can't get this guy.
Where the fuck would the supplies be?
I guess it would be on the other side?
Okay, but we'll get rid of these guys first.
Wish they'll stand still.
How would I hit- God damn it.
It was close.
Ding.
The stomach is almost the ball.
It's like almost there.
I can go this way.
What the fuck was that?
Oh,
wait, they saw me?
How?
It was another sniper!
Oh, that was a different sniper?
Where are you?
Okay.
There's another sniper.
Okay, now I know.
I didn't realize that meant sniper.
That's not fair!
The stupid wind!
Okay, that's fine.
No, don't close it!
No!
That's not good!
You know what that means?
There you go.
We still have another chance.
That's what he said.
They're not escorting him.
There's no way they will escort him away from me.
They cannot escort him away from me.
Where is he anyway?
Where would he be?
I refuse to let him go.
This should be it.
Come on.
No!
I was so close!
Is it like this base?
The one I'm in right now?
This one?
Or this one?
Oh, shit!
Wait!
He's in here!
He's right here!
Oh, shit!
What am I doing here?
Okay, this is practice.
Alright.
I gotta get the other sniper though.
I can't figure out where the other sniper is.
Where is this other sniper that got me?
This fucker!
I hate this guy!
Holy fuck!
Okay, I wanted to get him out of the way first.
Okay.
Let's get down.
Where the fuck is the supplies?
Yeah, I know!
But where is it?
Is it this?
Oh, we found it!
Nice!
Okay.
Alright.
It's time to figure out how to get there.
Okay.
This is a little difficult.
We're in difficult territory because we have to get to the...
We have to get here.
Like, to find him.
Like, how?
This is a big area.
Alright.
We gotta figure out how to get there.
To kill Hitler right here.
We gotta figure out first how the fuck do we get there.
Now the actual hard part.
Happy Thanksgiving.
This is where the real game begins.
He's already there?!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I fucked around way too much!
Happy American Thanksgiving.
The best way to celebrate.
Wait, he's already doing a tour?!
I'm still trying to figure out how to get to him!
Okay.
How long does he tour for?
Does he leave?
It's time!
Oh, I gotta...
I gotta fucking...
Oh god,
okay.
Alright, I gotta figure out how to get there.
I'm booking it as fast as I can.
He stops touring at 19?!
Wait, why did he stop?
He stopped!
Okay.
Okay, I need to kill this guy.
That's a sniper.
No!
I had to reload!
I had to...
No!
I just tried...
No, I was trying to reload!
Oh my god, I hate this.
I was trying to reload, my god.
Oh my god, which way was it?
Okay, I'm gonna try this again.
Why did you turn over?
I wanted to hit him from above, but I fell.
No, it wasn't a sound.
What are you talking about?
Like, I can't do it from here!
Okay.
I wanted to headshot him.
I thought it'd be cool.
I'm gonna shoot his arm.
Fuck.
No!
Do you know what that means?
It's a message!
I had to...
I had to send him...
I will kill him.
I will... this is my...
I don't care about Hitler anymore.
I need to kill this guy in particular.
What?
How do I shoulder swap?
I don't remember how.
How do you shoulder swap?
I don't remember.
I need to check the commands.
This is my turn.
I would specifically look for the command to shoulder swap.
Oh, it's untoggled.
Okay.
Shoulder aim.
Alright, we'll make it the right...
The right shift key.
Wait, what?
Oh no, it's the aim.
Wait, no.
Wait, no, it doesn't swap it.
It just swaps it like the shoulder.
Pick up body, defuse.
Wait, they don't have it!
I don't... they don't have it!
Is it camera swap?
This is personal.
I will kill you.
I'm done.
That's all I want.
Okay, okay, I'll go different now.
I got what I wanted.
Guys, I got...
Guys, I got what I wanted.
I'm fine now.
I got the achievement.
I didn't even know there was an...
Wait, what?
What?
How?
Is it because I ran?
Goodbye.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I ran.
They heard me running.
I can't believe it.
Okay, we're gonna get there.
We will fucking get there if it's the last thing I fucking do.
No, it's just funnier to...
What's this?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
What is that?
Oh man, that's what it is, the shoulder swap.
What the fuck?
What?
What do I do?
Will they come out?
Can I crawl under the gun?
But how do I prone again?
Guys, how do I prone?
Is there a prone?
I don't know if there's a prone, right?
Sprint, stance...
There's no prone.
Is it hold crouch?
No.
I can't.
They saw me.
That's fine.
We'll die to get there.
We will die to get there.
We can't.
You can't fucking crawl while you're proning.
This is so bullshit.
This is fucking bullshit.
You can't.
I tried.
I nearly tried.
Oh my god.
I need to get to him.
You can't?
How?
It won't let me.
Look, see?
I can only like, do that.
It nearly won't let me.
Just prone.
I don't
know, maybe I'm doing it wrong.
But it didn't let me.
I'm scared of like, sprinting.
I need to find him.
He's like here somewhere.
He's checking the boats.
Wait,
how do I?
Wait a minute.
I can't get across.
How do I get across?
Wait a minute.
Okay, this is awkward.
Because I don't know how.
I don't know how to get across.
I think I'm stuck here.
Wait, you can?
Oh, there's an entrance right here.
Okay, I figured it out.
It's like right over here.
It's so tiny.
Ceremony.
I want to go to the ceremony.
Fine.
That's fine.
They didn't hear it.
There we go.
It was silent.
Woah, woah, woah.
I gotta figure out where that ceremony is being held.
Where is this ceremony being held?
Oh, this was where he was touring earlier, but I was too late!
I gotta find where all the people are.
Okay.
Alright, we got this guy.
Oh!
No!
I don't think he knows.
I don't think he knows, guys.
I don't think he knew.
How is there wind here?
Oh, did I have my scope at 100?
Oh, it still worked, though.
It still worked.
That makes so much more sense now.
I was like, why is that working?
Where am I?
Also, where the fuck am I?
I'm trying my best to find him!
I didn't figure out how to get out of here!
Am I beneath him?
There's no way.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, this fucking sucks.
He's so far.
Okay, but first off, before I...
Okay.
But like...
No!
I still got the headshot.
I have to get this shot first.
Okay.
Alright.
I got this shot.
We need to make sure we actually kill him first.
We gotta make sure.
We gotta make sure we actually kill him before we do the real shot.
Just saying that we do care.
You know?
Alright, this is...
God fucking...
Okay.
God damn it!
The fucking wind!
The wind!
How does he dodge it?
Okay.
Are you...
What?
I don't understand!
How do you dodge it?
Okay.
How?
Where's your fucking ball?
That's so slow and steady!
The shot could end the war, guys.
This shot!
You fucker!
I just... At least I got his lungs.
I got his lungs!
I got...
Oh my god.
This shot could end the war!
Right here.
I...
Not even gonna adjust it.
Oh.
Oh wait, he didn't even hear it.
Oh my god, you know what?
I know why.
I know why!
Wait.
Okay!
That has to be something!
Right there!
My bird!
No!
Okay.
We did it!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
You guys hear that?
The shot could end the war, guys.
This shot...
God damn it, it's his ass!
This is personal now.
Oh no.
I didn't mean to save it.
Easy does it.
This shot could end the war, guys.
Right here.
Oh my god, that's the leg!
Oh, that's the feet!
No.
We won't get this shot.
No!
God!
This will end the war!
You don't understand!
This shot will end the war.
Hit him!
Ideally!
It's there!
I can get a headshot!
I can get a leg shot!
But, like, I just...
Oh my god, he needs to...
Oh, his balls.
His fucking balls.
His stupid balls.
Where is the ball?
Where is it?
No!
It was right there!
I see it!
His cone is covering it up!
It was right there!
I'm gonna shoot you in the balls if I have to.
I'm mad.
I'm so mad.
I'm getting closer.
There's no way.
Did I accidentally overwrite it?
No!
Wait!
I'm 19.
Oh no.
Wait.
Wait, is this the one?
Oh, there we go.
We're okay.
Easy does it.
This shot will save the war.
This shot can end the war.
Easy does it.
Yes!
No!
His hamstring!
I got his fucking knee.
No!
It's a stupid knee.
Okay.
We're getting better though.
This shot can end the war.
It's this one.
It's right here.
That's where the ball is.
No.
Oh my god!
It's where the ball is!
The shot that could end the war!
We need a death shot that can end the stupid war!
Easy does it.
This shot can end the war.
Guys, did you hear?
This shot could end the war.
Come on.
Right here.
Oh my god, that was his leg.
That has to be it.
That's it!
I see it!
I see the ball!
I see it.
It's right there.
It's actually right there.
Okay.
I see it.
I see where it is.
That's the worst part!
This shot could end the war.
Okay.
No, I can't.
I have to have him walk to me.
I'm just gonna take this headshot.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna take the head.
How many times do I have to kill you?
How many times?
How many times must I kill you?
Until I get what I want!
The wrong head.
How much more?
Move!
Walk!
Start walking.
Is that it?
Where did I shot him in the ass?
Where?
What was that shot?
Did I get him in the fucking ass?
Where was that?
This shot could end the war.
Oh my god, this is it.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Let's go!
Yes, V!
Yeah!
Yeah, that's right!
I did it, yeah!
We were all here!
We got the bots!
Yeah!
That's right, it was me!
I shot that end of the war!
I did that!
Let's go, I ended the war.
I fucking ended the war, guys.
How do I get out of here now?
The shot!
The shot that ended the war!
We were all here!
We were all- chat, thank you for the super chat!
We did it, guys!
We're here for the shot that ended the war, everybody!
You were all part of it!
We don't need a sniper anymore!
We ended the war!
No more nut!
We did it!
It was us!
No more sniper!
Retired!
No more- we ended the war, did you guys hear?
We ended the war!
That's what they told me!
They said if I got the shot, I'd end the war!
That's what they said, is it not true?
Is that not true?
I ended the war!
It's over!
The war is over!
Remember who ended the war?
He said it could not, that it would.
It's fine.
We did it, we did our job.
She is- I don't know how to get out!
Oh, it's this way!
Wait, am I going the right way?
I don't know!
Wait, it's this way.
This way.
It's fine, I figured it out.
I'm doing it!
I figured it out, the shot that ended the- oh my god!
Oh god, oh god, how are you still alive?
Oh my god, how am I still alive?
It's okay, we're so healthy right now.
Oh, you think- oh, I shot his ball, you think I don't?
Oh, beat your fucking head.
Oh, you fucking- that's right!
What the fuck?
This guy thinks it is Apex.
That's right, walk away.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna shoot you in the fucking intestine and slide.
That man hit the power slide.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you think I'm scared?
I literally shot him in the balls.
Okay, I need some medkits though, I'm a little scared.
Wait, what did Carl Williams say?
My superchance, it went too fast because I did it.
What do you say, guys?
Oh no, I'm a little fucked up right now.
Jesus Christ, I can't- I can barely peek.
Get out of here.
He gave me a med- You're a goddamn hero.
That's fucking right I am.
That's right.
Now you know.
Now you know what I could do.
Oh shit.
Now you know what I could do right now.
It's starting now.
Starting now you know what I can do.
Now you know what I'm capable of.
I need to get out of here first though.
Okay.
How are you alive?
Child!
Oh no, I gotta figure out how to get out of here.
Oh no, this is bad for me.
Oh no.
Wait, oh I didn't see him!
Get out of here!
That's it, I'm running and gunning.
That's it.
Starting now.
Starting- okay.
Starting now!
Okay, now I fucking am running.
Oh no!
Mac, thank you for the- Why are they all so mad?
I don't understand.
I don't know why they're so mad.
Like, it's like I killed somebody very important.
Why are they all so mad?
I fucking- I'm getting- I have no idea.
What could they be so mad about?
I wonder why.
Like, what did I do to piss them off, guys?
What could it be?
Oh god, there's people behind me too.
Oh, I'm like stuck here in a really bad place.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, it's cause I have- Come on, get out of here.
I know you're there.
There we go.
Oh my god, okay, I'm medkit.
Alright.
I told you it was the shot that could end the war.
There's like one guy here.
Where are they?
Oh my god, I can't walk over cause I don't know where the last two people are here!
Oh, that's- Okay.
Let's try them in the heart.
Oh no, I don't have a lot of heals left.
I can't run!
Oh shit.
No!
I pinned down!
I pinned down somebody!
SOS!
Doki has taken the shot!
She requires assistance!
She needs reinforcements.
SOS!
She took the shot!
No!
Saving private Doki, I'm sending an SOS message right now!
I can't get out of here!
SOS, private Doki needs help!
Are you serious?
Peek your fucking head, you coward!
If I could, I would also shoot you in the ball.
Oh, you have two balls, so like...
It'd be fine for you.
SOS, private Doki needs backup!
She's pinned down!
She's pinned down, she needs assistance!
Is this how you treat your heroes?
SOS!
Oh my god, I am not doing okay right now.
I am absolutely not doing okay.
Bro, fuck this particular railing!
Guys, guys, it's like they sent everybody here and I don't...
No!
SOS!
I need to escape!
But how?
How do I escape from here?
It's like I killed their leader or something!
It's actually crazy!
Oh my god, this guy has like... How come I can't do that?
Why can't I just run around and dodge all the bullets?
I don't know, it seems a little unfair.
Not gonna lie.
The fact that he could just do that...
Oh my god, okay, that's... I admire the spirit there.
I admire that.
Empty lung, that's fucking right.
Okay, wait.
Wait, who the fuck shot me?
Oh, he's still alive over there.
Wait, who still shot me?
Oh shit.
Okay, I didn't realize that guy was still alive.
Is that it?
What's it say?
Please tell me, don't take that shot.
Oh my god, he has a band-aid.
He has one band-aid.
Oh my god, look at all these bodies.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're making it out, boys!
We're making it out!
We're making it out of here!
Fucking hell, nobody has a fucking band-aid.
Not even one.
Not even one singular band-aid.
What is wrong with all of you?
Oh my god, he's right here.
Oh my god, please.
That's fine.
No, that's bad.
That's not fine.
That's okay, that's okay.
That's fine, that's fine.
That should hit.
Is that a headshot?
Let's go!
Okay, we should save.
We run.
We book it.
We can make it.
We can make it!
We fucking book it!
They don't know I'm here.
Okay, I ran the wrong way, but that's okay.
They don't know.
Oh my god, I swear, I was like thinking I would trip and actually die.
I was like doing my look.
Oh my god, there's so many!
It's the only way.
They don't know.
How do I get there?
That was the right one, but I put a mine over there.
Okay, I disabled my mine.
Okay, I gotta hope they step on this mine then.
I gotta hope they step on this mine.
They must step on the mine, right?
Do you think I can jump?
Oh, that's a lot of them.
That's a lot of them.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Watch this.
They're gonna step on it.
Oh, yes!
Where am I?
Oh no, we're fucked.
Where the fuck was the sniper?
Where is the sniper?
Where was he?
I didn't know where he was!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine, we got the infuses.
Okay.
I can put another one down.
Okay, everything will be fine.
I can jump through this window.
We're so healthy.
They wouldn't know.
Oh my god, I could have done that.
I could have just done that.
I could have just jumped through the window.
I didn't realize I could do that.
We're making it alive!
We're getting out of the
- We did it!
We took the shot at the end of the war.
I told you.
I told you we would take the shot at the end of the war.
I told you the shot would end it.
The fall at the end of the war.
We fucking did it.
Oh my god.
You're welcome everybody.
I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking hero.
Dragoons, thank you for the super- Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
You might say that was a pretty baller shot.
Thank you pretty Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not about how long it took us to get there.
It's about being a fucking hero.
Oh my god, that was fun.
That was fun.
I'm glad I got a chance to play Sniper Elite.
Oh my- that was actually incredibly fun.
I really enjoyed this game.
I didn't realize I even played for three hours.
Oh my god.
Time really like passed by so fucking fast playing that game.
Yeah, it was so fun.
I really actually really enjoyed it.
Time passed by incredibly fast that I didn't even realize I was playing it for three hours already.
Focused on my mission.
I told you.
I told you eventually.
Eventually.
Eventually the shot would hit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The loss of one ball led to the war.
The loss of a second ended.
The cycle of torsion, if you will, is complete.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
November never felt so dangerous.
I mean, I only shot two balls.
Like, I only shot...
No, I shot three balls today.
Guys, if you think about it.
So technically only two people failed the challenge.
So you have three more days or that's what's gonna happen.
Oh my god, I had so much fun, guys.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching today.
I definitely had a lot of fun playing the game.
I love the slow-mo.
The slow-mo was...
I don't know any...
I don't know why you would ever turn off the slow-mo though.
Cause that shit was so fucking fun.
Anyway, submit that...
Don't submit how many attempts it was.
But submit that clip where I got the shot for FPS VTuber.
FPS VTuber of the year.
That should've been my clip.
Look, the only reason why I failed some of those shots was the win, chat.
The fucking win.
I forgot to compensate for the win.
It was the win, guys.
I was the VTuber that ended the war.
There was win.
Did you not see how many windows there were, chat?
Did you not see the windows?
The guys messed me up.
The win fucked me up, guys.
I'm a hero.
You are talking to a hero right now.
The amount of times I've killed this man.
You're talking to a fucking hero.
I'm tearing up.
I literally rewinded time to end his bloodline several times, chat.
So, I am like hero times five at least.
He went through his own Crown Hog day.
Yeah, basically.
Hey, guys.
You guys didn't know.
We have less than a week left for Gamer Sups.
So, after that, it's gone forever.
So, you won't be able to get these after the week is left.
So, less than a week, guys.
And the amount of sales determines if I'll get a flavor or not.
So, yeah.
The support really does mean a lot, guys.
So, thank you so much for buying.
We already made like almost 6,000 sales already.
Which is pretty crazy, in my opinion.
So, thank you, guys.
On the cups alone.
Just for the cups, we already sold almost 6,000 on just the cups alone.
So, thank you, guys, so much.
It really does mean a lot for those people who bought it.
And for those who are retweeting it.
Even if you can't afford it.
For talking about the Gamer Sup Cup and everything.
So, I really do appreciate it, guys.
Thank you, guys, so much.
Also, if you guys didn't know.
I was nominated for...
I don't know about VTuber of the Year.
But like...
I got nominated for several nominations for VTuber Awards.
So, please vote for me.
And vote for yourself, too.
For the Fanbase.
The Dragoons.
The WrestleTuber.
Dragoons.
WrestleTuber.
FPS.
VTuber of the Year.
And VTuber of the Year.
I'll be very surprised for VTuber of the Year.
Because like...
The competition is very, very hard.
Like, the campaign...
Oh, my God.
It feels just like Student Council all over again.
Like...
Campaigning people I've been doing for VTuber of the Year was fucking...
I was like...
Oh, I'm scared.
So...
But, yes.
I'll make a Twitter post about it tomorrow.
I don't like doing too many work tweets.
Like...
Not work tweets.
But like...
Like formal tweets.
Like...
Because I already did like three formal tweets today.
And I don't like doing too many formal tweets a day.
So, like...
That's why I'm like...
If anything...
If I don't win anything...
I want you guys to win Fanbase of the Year.
Because...
Without you guys...
Like...
Still supporting me.
Since February.
Even before February.
And like...
Being strong.
And still supporting me.
In February.
Until now.
Like...
It really...
You guys deserve like Fanbase of the Year at least.
So, yeah.
I really appreciate.
Also...
Members.
Member goons.
We are going to have...
Our membership wallpaper.
Either today or tomorrow.
Woah.
Sorry.
This is the outfit.
Our outfit for the membership wallpaper.
So, yeah.
Look forward to seeing our membership...
November wallpaper.
Later today or tomorrow.
Depending on like...
If I gonna ever get the...
I think...
I don't know if the file is up yet.
But...
Yes.
It is winter themed.
So...
So, yeah.
Look forward to that.
This is the outfit.
This is the outfit for the winter...
For the winter wall...
For the November wallpaper.
So, yes.
Look forward to that.
Anyway.
Let me read it.
Back to this.
But, yes.
This is like...
If you are a member.
We do monthly wallpaper.
So...
You can download...
And it's like...
You can download all the wallpapers and everything.
So...
Yeah.
Remember to get some free wallpapers.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest my voice.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Oh, wait.
I said I was gonna talk about something after.
Wait.
What was it?
Was it just about like...
Fucking...
Wanting to move out of Canada?
I don't remember.
I was like...
Oh, yeah.
I wanna talk about something more after this.
I don't remember what it was.
What was it?
I don't remember.
Was it more about moving out of Canada?
Because I fucking hate...
Hate how like...
I can't see a fucking doctor.
That was it?
Oh, I think I talked about it most of...
Most of it in the beginning anyway.
Yeah.
Anyway.
So...
No.
I just really hate...
I just really hate that like...
I can't see a doctor.
And like...
I wanna...
I've been talking...
I've been thinking about...
I literally thought about it today.
I thought about it today.
Because I was like...
Really frustrated about it.
And everything.
And then...
So like...
I was thinking about like...
About...
But I'm not sure.
I'm not like...
Literally, I had this thought today.
So we'll see how it goes.
We'll see.
Apparently, they're like...
Oh, wait until 2025.
Maybe it'll get better.
And I'm like...
What?
Are we just gonna have like...
Fucking thousands of doctors suddenly appear in 2025?
Like...
Like I'm just...
I'm like...
That's not possible.
USA doctors are...
But at least you can see them.
You can't even get an appointment.
That's...
It doesn't matter if you have the money.
You...
You can't even get an appointment.
That's the worst part.
Anyway...
Anyway, guys.
That's really it.
I'm thinking about it.
But like I said.
It's not like I'm gonna move right now or anything.
We'll just see how it goes.
We'll see how it goes.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.